how are you chuck I'm doing great man
I'm doing really good they tell me how
nice play call of that last play last
night what was that call Charles death
call strictly luck but you know what the
heck of a game over the heck of a game
yeah and I wonder about that that do you
practice that he's your best player but
how do you practice something like that
or do you well I thought that that uh
Duke really ran a awful last place
number one because you know they
couldn't get the last shot so when you
can't get the last shot you just get a
good shot and for some reason they end
up waiting waiting and then they took a
bad shot and then city of Syracuse just
got lucky because the kids just clearly
he didn't call glass but I was
disappointed in a CEREC excuse me Duke
because you know it was about 39 seconds
when they got the ball and instead of
just running a plague in a good shot
they milk the clock but into some
unknown reason and then 13 just hit a
lucky shot I never understood that that
if I have a good shot but you know my
coach is saying let's drain the clock as
much as we get I'd rather have the right
shot at the right time as opposed to
trying to force something as you you
know the shot clock starts to expire why
is that because if you I'm sitting here
and I was sitting there watching and I'm
like well you can't get the last shot
yeah and I just thought it was a bad
possession by Duke and then hey good
Syracuse crazy hit the kid hit a lucky
shot it was a good basketball game I
don't know if you saw this last night
there was a moment a couple of nights
ago with John Calipari where he's doing
a halftime interview on the mothership
and then the Missouri fans start
chanting you suck and then he said all
right you know I'm gonna stop and go to
the locker room Rick Pitino last night
at North Carolina somebody said
something and then he was ready to go
back he was going into the stands after
half
this heckler I got I I understand you
know Calipari just saying I'm not gonna
listen to this but Pitino was going into
the stands after this guy like what
would be over the top where you would
see now I I know you had your moments
but a coach going into the stands here
Charles well I've always believed that
every coach and every player should be
able to bring one fans out of the stands
to meet him at half-court and so you say
what you said to me to my face and if he
says there's what he said you should get
to beat the hell out of him I've been
standing up for 25 years dad every NBA
player every coach college of pros some
of these fans have been way out of line
for years and y'all give them a ticket
and you think they can say anything they
wouldn't say that stuff to your face man
the man they only do it when they're
protected by the crowd and television
comes and things like that but like I
say I believed for years every fan every
NBA player every coach should be able to
bring a fan down the half-court if they
say exactly what you said to me Andy and
you can't even get arrested it should be
like gladiator type stuff he just beat
the hell out of them right there on the
spot I guarantee they would not do it
again yeah I know their fans are gonna
say stuff and sometimes they're funny
but when when they go overboard usually
you know you'll hear something racially
you know charged and then I you know if
I'm african-american I can't let that
just slide the other stuff if somebody
says you suck or you're fat or okay but
if somebody says something like that
then you know I'm I'm going into the
crowd dumb beat you with my shoe a few
times for hitting fans and every time I
beer that they deserved it
I've never felt bad about it they
actually deserved it they know they were
wrong like I said man some of these fans
been out of hands for many years there's
a certain amount of jealousy because
guys make so much money
clearly there when you're black they
have said some things or made some
sounds that were inappropriate and you
should have the right to beat them down
you always don't get in trouble but you
know what every time I beat them and got
in trouble I slept good
next night I always felt bad for Patrick
Ewing with what he went through starting
in high school and then at Georgetown
and you know when you're around Patrick
I mean he can't can't be a nicer guy but
just the racial stuff and they were
throwing bananas on the basketball floor
me I I mean that's remarkable that you
know he he put up with that or had to
put up with that well I'll tell you two
things about Patrick Ewing he may be
that I've been an MBA for thirty years
he might be the nicest guy never a
superstar obviously the nicest guy ever
been around at all so I think it's a
travesty he hasn't gotten a head
coaching job yeah he's one of the few
guys he's wanted a few great players in
NBA history who actually went the
assistant coach route route hardly one
pronounced it and it's paid his dues but
I think he's one of the nicest people
I've ever met and like it's a it's a
travesty that he's never gotten a head
coaching job I mean some of these other
bombs they'd hire and fire this guy
can't get even get a look and I just
think that's the travesty
he's Charles Barkley NBA on TNT I agree
with you we've had Patrick on quite a
few times and hoping that he would get
you know that final interview to become
a head coach Magic Johnson is going to
mean what to the lakers front office
well he's gonna work this behind all
he's gonna try to do a good job you know
it's dan is tough right now because
nobody has in their patience you know
we're drafting these 18 year old kids 19
year old kids and you're not gonna know
anything about that but three or four
years so that's the biggest obstacle I
mean you look at the Lakers now you got
D'Angelo Russell you got a roundel and
you got Brandon Ingram and you think
they might be good players but you're
not gonna know for another couple of
years
I think madam it's always going to be
successful because he's a hard-working
guy but man it's tough you know because
all these guys in the NBA want to play
together now so you don't you have to
all like same thing but you know
apologize is a hell of a player now he
wants to move on
so the
it's got it's killing the NBA and to be
honest with you because we don't have
that many good teams would you like in
regard that would you hired magic he can
do just wait why not you know I'm just
curious if no no it makes me laugh when
I've heard some of this stuff going
around we who you think got a better
chance of being successful Mattie jumper
Jim but I think it's funny how is such a
double standard they hire somebody's
other people who got no clue about
sports game magic a chance
I listed effect if I had on an NBA team
it somehow to see what you hired Jim Bob
at Magic Johnson I'm like I'm on how
Magic Johnson okay let me put you let me
put it to you this way you you own a
team and you can hire Michael Larry or
magic in your front office but only one
wow that's a great question
that's a great question uh-uh wow that
is a great question Dan I don't normally
get stuff that often well Michael has
been better he's done a much better job
lately
he was obviously struggling in the
beginning Larry's done a very good job
in in Indiana he's done a very good job
and magic hasn't had this chance yet so
I really can't that's a really tough
question you know my affinity for
Michael I would love to see him be
really really successful but Byrd has
done a fantastic job in Indian they've
been competitive for the last 10 years
or more but also you know magic ever had
his chance but I would like I say that's
a great question Dan I don't think
there's a wrong answer
feels like bird might have been well
Birds been more successful from being a
coach and also being a GM Michael yeah
yes a bird would birds probably the
right answer because of what what roles
he's been in yes I would agree with that
the magic hasn't had his chance and
Michael has he has struggled at times
obviously he's struggled at times of a
bird has the best track record who
should be traded today well if I Jimmy
Butler should be traded if Paul George
is going to leave Indiana next year they
should be traded but you can't have a
Kevin Durant situation you can't let him
just walk next year and get nothing for
him
you know if I'm just helping I make a
deal you have to save yourself if we
make a deal we might can beat Boston if
I don't make a deal I'm just gonna have
another 18 year old kid on my team
coming in next year and he's not because
they're you tell me loser Rookie of the
Year this year do we have one we don't
have one yeah what see this is one
reason I hate trapping these young high
school kids the two kids who have played
well are Murray from Denver who's played
well and also you got Brogdon from
Milwaukee the rest of these guys who are
drafting man did making zero difference
in the NBA zero difference and see what
bothers me about that damn it undermines
the integrity of the draft the draft is
designed for bad team to get help that's
what that's what I hate about this whole
thing the most it might if I'm a fan and
I'm a fan team sucks in all days you say
man I'm getting a Patrick Ewing I'm
getting a Michael Jordan I'm getting a
Magic Johnson you know I'm getting I'm
leasing a car Malone or John Stockton
now I'm getting a player who's probably
go in gonna help me for three or four
years does not fair to the fans that
bothers me so if I'm the Celtics and I
got a chance to get Jimmy Butler up
all George I'm saying yeah I'm gonna get
a lot of repect but he's not gonna be as
good at Jimmy Butler or Paul George and
next year I'm not gonna be that much
better next year so if the shop I'm the
scepters I'm close to
got a chance of beating the Cavaliers I
pull the trigger on a big deal
yeah that's why if I had a chance for
boogie cousins and I'm the Lakers I
would have brought him in because I got
one of the two best big men in the game
and you've got guys who are young and
developing but I I got somebody who I
can at least build around but you know I
I got one of the two best centers in the
game so I can start there somebody who
at least has talent and if I surround
him with you know good people in the
front office that he'll respect and
listen to then I got a chance no no it's
his fault - absolutely I start there
with him but it's just like when Rodman
came in to the Bulls you know he
respected Phil and Michael and he fell
in line there I think that there are
instances where you know I think Boogie
Cousins has got a whole lot of talent
and if you're the Lakers you're not
going anywhere
well tremendous amount of talent yeah I
think he's one of the most talented big
man I've ever seen
well let me tell you something your team
never wins you have to take some
responsibility you can't pass the buck
to Sacramento King you say well it was
Sacramento if your key if you never make
the playoff but that was always terrible
Charles that they've had six or seven
coaches the front office is a mess you
don't do with that they didn't hire you
the reason they can't fire coaches so he
kept getting them fired but secondly
that mess you put everybody talked about
all the bad players on their team did
you think if he was a better leader
those guys would have been better
you don't want boogie cousins on your
team I do not okay I do not but my
question is that everybody always want
to blame Sacramento and say he has none
to play with do you think if he was a
leader and he treated two other
teammates better you don't think some of
those young guys on that team would've
would have at least develop in the last
six or seven years well let's those guys
all the guys they were all a lot of
repeat they can't all be bad do you
think he made it such a toxic
environment that those young guys
couldn't grow up and mature well you
know what we're gonna find out now that
he's out of town that these guys are
gonna let's see if they develop well
they won't be the same because he's a
hell of a player but but I'm saying we
don't see what the truth is with him
with after the Davis now that's the big
question
I like it I've never I've never said
those guys in Sacramento a great great
player but if he hadn't been a better
leader and a better teammate they would
have been better
oh let me taste up now he gets a chance
he's playing with Anthony Davis and
through Holliday are some other players
down there now now we don't get to say
who thought it was for real now malli
just real I can't wait till the first
round of the playoffs when New Orleans
knocks off Golden State eight versus one
Charles I tell you what there I'll take
you to the big house you can play and
you can bring the dance with you too
I can afford dinner for them too I would
think I get a little more than a damn
steak if I predict the pelicans beat
Golden State Chuck I think I get this
how about I get a steak dinner and I get
a car I'm calling the greatest upset of
all time here how about just like a
hybrid or something like it not an
expensive car but just a car a
two-seater or something like that would
be nice I like all right fair enough so
I'll buy you a steak dinner and you'll
buy me a steak dinner with the Dennett's
and a Kia
so it's gonna be the same price your
dinner is going to be the same price as
my steak dinner and the Kia's far as
cost
Thank You Charles good to talk to you
again all right thank you all hi buddy
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]